Vladimir Putin has worn the West against
interfering in Ukraine saying that his
country would unleash counter-strikes
against threats he deems unacceptable
his comments that come as Russia makes
gains in Ukraine's east and south
Ukraine's defense Ministry says Russian
troops have captured several towns in
the Eastern donbass region meanwhile in
the besieged city of mariopol a
residents are facing increasingly
desperate conditions
[Music]
in the Ukrainian Capital cave
people sing for a passage to save day
for their fellow citizens in mariopol
but inside the besieged city
ordinary people do what they can to
carry on
queuing for hours for their pensions as
money Runs Out
we came to the pension fund to get in
line to register for our pensions
because money has run out the salaries
of pensioners who used to work have
stopped
a Ukrainian Commander inside the city's
astroval steelworks said hundreds of
injured civilians remain trapped
in our group there are more than 600
wounded fellows with different levels of
gravity they badly need medical help
here there are no conditions no medicine
no Personnel who could help them we have
wounded civilians we help them as much
as we can the information
clashed with Russian forces in the
occupied city of her son
after the former mayor was reappointed
by the Russians
the protester's message to their
occupiers was clear
go home
close to the front lines
in the eastern city of Hakeem
it's a daily struggle to survive with
what little they have
many are living in cramped basements
The Strain on their mental health is
clear
we are all going to end up in a mental
hospital all of us here are struggling
below Hakeem
Metro stations are now one of the few
safe places where children can play
a new life below the city away from the
dangers of Russian bombs
let's get the latest then from DW
correspondent Emmanuel Shaz in the Vive
in Western Ukraine oh welcome Emmanuel
and there's fighting not just in the
East but across the country
exactly I feel in fact you know here in
the river in the west of the country and
yet uh daily almost we do have air
strikes those extracts they are here in
the wave last week seven people died 13
people were injured because they are
military infrastructures that are of
interest for Russian forces
unfortunately uh missiles also fall on
civilians as was the case last week
there are such infrastructures that are
targeted by the Russians and also
Railway infrastructures which are of
interest for Russia because of course
Russia
imagines that weapons especially weapons
coming from western western allies will
circulate through the country either by
Road or by Railways so the efforts of
course are focused at the moment on on
eastern Ukraine when it comes to heavy
bombing a constant shelling in donbassy
in Donetsk on Harrison harkive Odessa
but the rest of the country is equally
under threat and many times a day you
would hear the sirens here and you would
have to take shelter until the end of
the alert
as we saw in your report this is taking
its toll on people's mental health and
tell us more about how people in
affected areas are reacting
well uh Phil I'll start by giving you a
figure in the region in the province of
luhansk that was initially before the
war at 350
000 inhabitants there's only 60 000
inhabitants left 290
000 people have fled they have fled
towards Western Ukraine they have fled
abroad in neighboring countries Poland
Romania Germany Slovakia that is to give
you an idea just how massive The Exodus
of all those people is in total there's
over 7 million displaced people within
Ukraine and over 5 million refugees in
neighboring countries and for those who
stay for example in the city of her son
in the south of the country well today
people were practicing in the city
center against uh Russian authorities
who have seized the city who have
established a Russian Administration in
the city they were protesting peacefully
those citizens while they were dispersed
with tear gas with stunned grenades as
well there were four civilians being
injured so people in those affected
regions are not accepting this Russian
occupation and today I was in a shelter
I met with some people from busha
Butcher and and harkiv and they those
were men those were able men and they
came here they want to train and they
want to come back to defend their cities
against the Russian Invader right now
the U.N Secretary General has now
arrived in Kiev what can we expect from
his talks with president zelanski
well Antonio guterres had met previously
on Tuesday of Vladimir Putin and he was
hoping that Russia would would let the
United Nations take part to a
humanitarian effort to evacuate
civilians who are still trapped in the
west affected areas and not least the
other steel plant in mariopol but here
authorities in Kiev are very skeptical
that any humanitarian Corridor could be
opened we've seen talks stalling over
the past a few weeks with even ngos
saying that probably what would be more
efficient than any negotiation towards a
humanitarian Corridor was would be a
real ceasefire of 24 48 72 hours to a
lot of civilians to to go away to take
shelter where they want and not to
follow a specific route route given by
the authorities
thank you for that Emmanuel Emmanuel
Shaz in levieve
so let's take a closer look at what
Vladimir Putin means when he you're
warned against it countries intervening
in moscow's war in Ukraine here he is
talking to Russian lawmakers today
if anyone from outside moves to
interfere in the current developments
and creates unacceptable strategic
threats for Russia
they should know that our response to
encounter these assaults will be
lightning fast
it will be quick
we have all the tools for this
the kind that no one else can boast of
right now
foreign
[Music]
Crump he's a CEO of global risk analysis
consultancy at sibling and a former
British tank commander welcome to DW is
President Putin stating the obvious
interfere and will come after you or is
there more to today's statement
I mean this is not the first time that
Russians have made statements along
these lines of course they've raised
this numerous times since the start of
the conflict and there's a repeat each
time of
a reaction to to the Western Supply of
weapons now that Western Supply weapons
is becoming more obvious you know
there's larger equipment being provided
there's more signature equipment being
provided it's no longer just defensive
so I'm certain that Russia is
increasingly being frustrated by this
but they're still responding by strikes
within Ukraine they haven't escalated
the conflict yet outside of Ukraine
um but I think the rhetoric will
eventually have to be followed by action
and maybe that's what we're seeing with
the imposition of restrictions on Poland
and Bulgaria in regard to gas it
potentially operations in cyberspace in
other areas where Russia can start to
extend the conflict and and express its
continued discontent the fact that this
support for Ukraine is of course helping
to hinder Russia's progress on the
battlefield the extension of this
conflict is is the interesting thing
isn't it because now we have these
mysterious explosions in moldova's
russia-backed Breakaway region that's
transnation which borders Ukraine on the
west and of course people are worried
now that this war is spilling over
um is that likely this spillover
I think you know again there's a very
good point that we don't need to
speculate too much around exactly what's
happening in transition for fear of of
starting rumors but I think it is worth
looking at how disorder and transnister
you know would benefit a different size
and I think clearly Russia benefits the
most from this and it does fit the
Russian Playbook of what happened in
Donetsk and luhansk
um you know a state of emergency was
generated that allowed mobilization and
right now for Russia being able to
operate forces from transistorian in
more Force than it currently has as you
said in the report 1500 soldiers at the
moment in transistria that's not enough
to move against Odessa or or even
pretend to move against Odessa
um but a few more forces mobilization
transistor Justified cause for
operations from there that supports
Russia's War aim that as declared
earlier in the week of moving towards
taking all of Southern Ukraine and for
now most importantly it allows Russia to
present enough of a threat to Odessa and
potentially to Michele as from the West
that it draws off Ukrainian forces from
the donbass it stops Ukraine from
reinforcing the main fight against
Russia so if you have to look at which
side benefits more from this it's
definitely Russia in the way it sits and
so I think suspicion is obviously going
to point that way that this is an
escalation to support Russia's War girls
just shifting the topics slightly I'm
intrigued by yesterday's meeting of
40-yard countries here in Germany
chaired by the U.S defense secretary
these are going to become a monthly
meetings to coordinate weapon supplies
to Ukraine
what do you think that Ukraine needs now
that the West isn't already providing
this is a short of of of air defense
cover
um what else would prove decisive in
this war
well and you mentioned
um aerial support and the rebuilding of
the Ukrainian Air Force and actually
some work has gone into spares for that
and uh Liz truss the UK foreign
secretary actually has now publicly said
we should be providing um actually
aircraft to Ukraine which was a red flag
in the conflict two months ago and I
think the fact we were even now having a
monthly donors conference shows how far
thinking has moved on from the early
days when the Assumption was that
Ukraine would be fighting an Insurgency
after a couple of weeks that Russia
would have taken much of the country and
it was going to be a different sort of
resistance what we're actually seeing
with full-fledged fighting uh in eastern
Ukraine in southern Ukraine and hence
that change in supplies you know Germany
now supplying anti-aircraft um armored
vehicles which are very effective
against drones low-flying helicopters
low-flying aircraft the sort of threats
we're seeing
um tanks being supplied to the point the
Ukraine maybe has more tanks now than it
started the conflict with uh which given
two months of fighting is astonishing
really and Russia certainly can't say
the same
um and I think you're going to see more
more focus on these War fighting
supplies rather than defensive Aid
rather than things that help in
Insurgency and I think that'll be
sustained but the most important thing
right now is artillery and well over 150
NATO caliber artillery pieces now
pledged to Ukraine with supporting
ammunition and Bulgaria supplying
soviet-era ammunition maybe one reason
that Bulgaria has been targeted and
picked out for these oil and sorry the
gas sanctions so that's how it's going
to keep developing that's very clear
thank you so much for that Justin Crump
from risk consultancy assembly